I think always create content where you
consume the most because you're going to
know the format better what's
resurfacing now is combination videos
like just think of a smoothie right you
combine cooking with a story time
diffusion is how you build an audience
the fusion is what makes you unique and
you found something that makes money
gets views and you like it Niche it down
Niche it down baby that's how you make
that coin
so what are the biggest trends that you
need to know in the Creator economy what
do you need to know from gen Z right now
that you can apply to your content as it
comes to making more of an impact
reaching more people and what does it
look like to be a next Generation leader
in the Creator economy today on the
think media podcast we have Jade Dharma
wongsa a 22 year old Phenom who is a
social entrepreneur the current CEO of
X8 media and influencer marketing agency
that works with tech platforms and Civic
movements she's also a creator with Tick
Tock YouTube 371 000 subscribers on
YouTube and so we're going to learn a
lot today Jade how are you Sean honestly
I'm gonna be for real I'm honored to be
here on the think media podcast because
for the longest time I thought it was
too relevant for you so thank you so
much for having me super fired up to
have you on and uh I've known you for a
while now it's been a while to watch
your journey yeah and you're still just
getting started but you've been doing
this for a lot of years for people that
are just meeting you what have you been
up to over the last when'd you start so
I started when I was nine years old my
first YouTube video ever 2010
um I don't think you're supposed to be
that age on YouTube I think you have to
be 13 but I broke the law yeah and you
know I've been I've been making content
for a long time and I knew I wanted to
be a full-time YouTuber since I was a
kid so this is I'm living the dream job
and I'm still producing content till
this day yeah so you're a full-time
YouTuber you're also active on Tick Tock
but you're also wearing a CEO hat yeah
if there was a pie chart how do you
break your time down it used to be 50 50
like CEO agency work 50 content but I
just have to be honest with myself I was
like I like content more yeah so I would
say right now it's 80 20. 80 content 20
CEO I love that and uh you recently just
did a panel here at VidCon in Anaheim
and it was on Next Generation leadership
the c-suite reimagined what are some of
your thoughts on what it means to run a
company in a Creator economy gen Z next
gen world I think it's just all about
age right and think we live in a world
where right now our leaders are going to
be older and it's hard to come in I felt
like it was hard to come in a space
where there's Legend Sean you know
veteran and I'm like the 16 year old
girl who doesn't really have that
experience and I think what it means is
age is now just a number but it's also
more based on your experience and what
you in your work versus like your race
your background and I think that's
really empowering for a lot of people
for me I didn't grow up with a lot of
money I started really young so I had to
rely on my work and let that be the
talking point to get clients to get
brand deals it was a it was a hard
hustle though I'm not gonna lie when it
comes to your story what role did your
parents play in you being an
entrepreneur a huge part I lucked out
not on the finances part but I lucked
out on having supportive parents who are
themselves very entrepreneurial minded
my dad runs apps like he builds apps he
my mom's an artist so like they've
always been like if you want to drop out
of high school which I did they let me
what have you learned wearing the CEO
hat of what it means to to lead people
on your team are they all young they are
all young they're all always they're all
like they're either younger or older
than me like I have someone who's 25 on
my team and like 12 I mean not 12. wait
that's not that's child labor I mean
like you know like 18 19. Jade comes on
the podcast and says she has child
there's a confession
it's on tape I don't I promise and so
when it comes to what people need to
know about gen Z what are some of like
the things especially uh you know I
turned 40 this year so I'm an elder
Millennial Elder Millennial yeah because
there's like younger Millennials and
other Millennials it's such a big
generation or something I don't really
are you closer to Gen X or closer to I'd
be closer to Gen X okay yeah and the
only reason I came up with that term was
there's a Liza's Netflix special I'm
forgetting your last name koshy no okay
uh Eliza she's a comedian anyway she did
a segment called elder Millennial and I
was like oh you identify that must be
what I am yeah because there is
Millennial and that's someone who's more
Millennial closer to gen Z so when it
comes to gen Z I mean breaking that down
first of all like what are maybe some
attributes of gen Z that if you're a
marketer a business owner that's trying
to think about how do I reach gen Z what
do people need to know I think
historically gen Z was anyone Under 12
to 24
who was basically born after 2000 I
would say is Gen Z I'm gonna be honest
gen Z is a huge Market to Market to
right now we're like the highest you
know consumer spending we buy anything
that's cool and trendy unfortunately we
have no brains we just keep consuming
products but
um you know I think I think we're
definitely a huge target market for a
lot of people because we're very
malleable and like easy to Market too on
social and um I think you know there's
also generation Alpha which I'm not
going to go into but some traits of gen
Z also include very very
um passionate unhinged I think we're the
generation that started all like the
social movements and all you know who
cares about like environmentalism so I
feel like we've been a pretty cool
generation for the most part there are
some problematic uh qualities like
cancel culture is a huge problem I feel
like with our generation but I can't
complain I'm a part of it
what are um some
strengths that
Elder creators could learn that gen Z's
doing well oh that's a really good
question I mean gen Z seems to be
maybe short form
um seems to be maybe grabbing you know
hooks there seems to be maybe a native
understanding of content so those things
just seem maybe observational but I
oftentimes think that as kind of the
younger generation goes it eventually
ages up and it sort of shapes all
content so I just know if there's maybe
attributes that you recognize I notice
for example you as a content creator
maybe you just were being yourself and
making this up but you were long
boarding around with a little wireless
mic storytelling in a parking lot on a
long board which if anything made me
think you were a being you but B you
were
keeping attention it was weird it was
unique and it seemed to be intelligent
you know quirky is a good word quirky is
like definitely a thing that Elder
Millennials can learn from gen Z just
just keep it keep it interesting I think
a lot of gen Z likes to make fun of
things that are called chugi have you
heard that word before yes and like did
someone call you chooky I didn't hear it
there's lots of viral uh vertical videos
of like gen Z breaking up
um there's you know I'm like in the
church world it's uh there was one that
was like uh your love is busting
busting everything I put my trust in it
was like a gen Z worship song I mean it
was like your love is dead ass and I was
like what
you know it's just gen Z language or
whatever you're familiar I'm glad no one
called you chewy because I feel like
that not yet not yet what does chugi
mean chugi's just cringe it's has no RIS
okay you heard of Riz give me the full
list what and Define the terms
okay sorry
yeah I said rizz is like you're cool
you're calm your quirky collected chooky
is the opposite you're trying too hard
to hear what people think so you want oh
like oh he's rizz yeah yeah you have
rizz or like you want your content to
have her is yeah what what does dead ass
mean means like for real like 100 100
what is what is on God on God means like
period period okay cat what is Cap no
cap cap No Cap means like like I'm not
lying like No Cap like my cap yeah so so
uh sometimes all like now I'm actually
doing up pretty good on Tick Tock mainly
because we're repurposing content
probably over 300 000 subscribers
followers or whatever whatever but
punchline
I'll sometimes say stuff that's of
course absolutely true but maybe it
seems Sensational and then somebody will
just drop the cap emojis
so they're saying that it's all cap
people think I'm lying it's just a bunch
of like oh this is cap and then to that
you reply to comment on Tick Tock and
you say you take your cap off
how like you take your cap off uh in
like a video yeah you can do video
replies on Tick Tock yeah you didn't
know you know you could do that on
shorts now yeah oh yeah yeah you started
yes you did it yes has it been effective
I think shorts is useful I think it
depends on your audience no I mean
shorts reply to comments oh no I haven't
done too much of that I don't know okay
this has been the already the most
unhinged podcast we've ever done by far
I'm sorry no cap on God by far this is
Sean you're good at this you're like gen
Z English I'm doing my best you're doing
so good comment below if Sean's selling
it but ultimately as far as what do
people need to know about gen Z this has
probably been a pretty good conversation
no you probably learned way more in
school uh oh no you yeah you did learn
more in school than this for sure I was
gonna say you learn more and think media
than in school but I think in this
episode context you're better off just
reading a book okay yeah YouTube Secrets
we're gonna bring it back though and
let's let's hit some more well I mean I
want to talk to you about your video
podcast about some of your tips and
strategies and some different things
that are working for you but uh let's
let's start there
you started a video podcast I did why
I'm just tired I mean to be honest like
I do a lot of short film content I do
YouTube videos are trendy people don't
really get to know you even if you make
like very long form content unless if
you're gonna say stuff that doesn't grab
Trey's attention and sometimes the
things that people get to know you about
isn't going to work on short form you
know so I built a podcast so my fans can
know me better and also I just feel like
in terms of a monetization tool it's
pretty lucrative so I we got so our
practice is called finesse I have a
podcast with my friend Cario we got a
presenting sponsor and it's like
honestly one of the most fulfilling work
too it's because like you're having
deeper conversations with people you're
interviewing people and it's awesome
what is a presenting sponsor it's like a
sugar daddy of podcasts like you get the
you know upfront payment for having
their brand
um in your podcast every episode For
What range of time did you do 12
episodes for a year
wait okay so you is a year-long contract
but you only had to shout them out in 12
of the episodes even if you upload more
no 12
and so we signed like a every episode
deal for 12 episodes one season got it
so so you're doing Seasons yes I'm doing
I'm I'm going professional yeah so
you're doing Seasons 12 episodes how
long does that take we're almost done
it's been eight uh eight months six
months so so you're not trying to do
weekly no we're doing bi-monthlies like
twice a month and any tips if somebody
wanted to get a presenting sponsor how
to network around
work that out I 100
um I actually have great advice on this
so our pockets is called finesse it'll
be 100 finesse this presenting sponsor
because we didn't have any viewership on
our podcast we didn't have any metrics
that could show us that we could you
know kill it but you know it's just kind
of like getting investment for towards
like a startup you the the brand needs
to believe in you as a Founder you as a
Storyteller and we told the story really
strongly finesse is about teaching
creators and Founders that you can do
anything you can start a business even
if you don't have capital or if you
don't have money and our sponsor not
sponsored it's called fourth wall and
they're like a platform to help creators
do that so it just it just worked out
and um my my co-host is also so happens
to be one of the most talented Talent
agents so that also was a plus and now
that you've posted a few episodes what
have you learned about posting online
they go on YouTube uh they go they go on
YouTube yeah do they though did I
actually check and maybe only the shorts
went on YouTube but you put audio
elsewhere or do you put the full video
podcast up oh you're the full videos
only on uh fourth wall and Spotify okay
so fourth wall is separate destination
yes it's kind of like it's kind of like
um a landing page for our like a home
base okay so you could listen to your
video podcast on fourth wall or Spotify
apple or apple music everywhere yeah all
that and then on YouTube You're Just
uploading clips clips yes and click you
but you might share some clips on your
socials as well exactly you post a lot
of Clips do you post a lot of clips from
a podcast that's what we do now that's
basically our entire Tick Tock you need
to make that little gen Z conversation a
clip right there like that whole little
interaction yeah you got it okay all
right noted um taking notes okay so and
then anything else you've learned since
doing a podcast because a lot of people
want to launch their own maybe tips
growth topics how to yeah have
conversations is it always just you two
talking about something topical it's
always that and we interview people who
are really cool if we if we are able to
find cool people which I feel like you
would be one of them but I think one of
my biggest tips is try your best not to
be I don't know if this is a roast to
think media but like try not try your
best not to be just
it's really easy to basically do like
content that's about other people and if
you don't build personality it's hard to
retain that audience I mean I've learned
it trust me I've done this with
finessing and initially our first five
episodes was just interviewing people
yeah and then when we did a solo episode
no one cared and we're like okay like
this is something that we want to work
on so I learned okay there needs to be a
healthy balance of solo a little bit of
I mean you've done a great job like you
have your own channel but it's like
really important not just to be an
interview podcast because there's a lot
out there you have to differentiate
yourself with either your personality or
a solo or something like that it's
really good and that's not a roast think
media podcast is three years old this
week was all been so low we just we've
been shooting lots of solo rounds that's
good it's probably 50 solo round okay
then you got it and they perform very
good and there's that I think there's a
pretty strong relationship let me know I
love you think media podcast especially
if you're on YouTube I know you can't
comment anywhere else
um if you what do you like better
interviews solo rounds but I just love
you Sean just like I'm here for Sean I
love you
um and yes so that's that's a great tip
so you actually have that depth you
actually have that connection when it
comes to YouTube versus tick tock
what say you
let's say you I mean at this point I
think I treat YouTube as my diary Tick
Tock as my capture attention to to drive
people to the diary unfortunately now
but there's so many short-term platforms
it's kind of getting blurred so now I
just treat it as each platform has its
own funnel like so for example shorts is
the top of the funnel and they drive
into my long form which is the YouTube
long-form Vlogs Tick Tock I have like
short form tick tocks that are like
Clips trending but I also have a long
form like day in my life that are three
minutes because Tick Tock also released
a new Creator fund it's like RPM like
YouTube money and you can get actually a
lot more money than
initially Tick Tock Creator fund was I'm
actually atcentifies now to post more
long form like 10 minute videos on Tick
Tock which is a whole other conversation
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com well I
just heard at the YouTube room here uh
from DJ that a million views on Tick
Tock if it's over a minute yes a
thousand dollars which is pretty good
it's really good for tick tock and for
vertical video and for vertical video so
the future is bright but the he said the
frustrating part was if you put energy
into that content not because it's over
a minute
you're gonna have to edit it more for
YouTube shorts if you just want to use
the same piece
which is fine but you know so maybe you
shoot for 105 and then just fine five
seconds in a different version exactly
but you're talking like three minutes on
Tick Tock why not 10 because can't you
do ten you can do 10. I scroll past
people who post how many Vlogs I think
three minutes is a good start but I'm
trying did you have anything else to say
you mentioned it's a whole other Creator
fund or Tick Tock or you were you were
gonna say something else was I gonna say
something else I don't know I could make
something up you said I have a lot more
we could talk about there oh yeah I have
a lot more we can talk about there
I mean like in terms of like long-form
content on Tick Tock I think we're just
scratching the surface but
um I feel like every platform at the end
of day wants to be a YouTube plus Tick
Tock hybrid like everyone wants to have
that love child where you have people
who come for the quick bits and then
stay for the long form and if you can
master that ratio of like whether it's
50 50 or 80 20 like I think that's how
you build the audience so let's pretend
you were a young person because
obviously that ship is sailed you're old
now I'm old now relax that was a joke
and uh but you are starting from scratch
yeah because you I mean you've been
doing this since you were nice that's 13
years in the game it's kind of crazy it
is crazy and so you're starting from
scratch what do you what platform do you
start on and with what type of content I
always tell people this
like my first tip is make a hundred can
I cuss or no yeah okay why did you say
videos well videos isn't make a hundred
what were you gonna say finish the
sentence make a hundred what's the I
just want to know now well make a
hundred videos that don't
that don't um on what platform honestly
whatever you so I think always create
content where you consume the most
because you're going to know the format
better don't try to make tick tocks if
you don't know the culture the language
if you love YouTube just double down and
you can repost on Tick Tock right so
double down on what platform you love
the most I think I would personally
start with YouTube
um and then you can make 100 tick tocks
or 100 YouTube shorts and focus on only
just understanding how to edit and
produce and be interesting I think a lot
of people focus on how to get views and
optimize when they don't even know how
to talk how to edit how to like get
comfy how to start and just treat your
100 videos as making videos for fun and
I always say like recreate your top 10
favorite YouTubers top 10 videos like
that's a good start like look at look if
you like Sean's video maybe to recreate
his top tip actually
you probably get a lot of that but like
you know like start there and you now
you have 100 videos right so make a list
of your top 10 people find the top 10
videos start there and then optimize you
don't need to overthink the beginning
okay so that's how you would start if
you went into this now knowing
everything you know wanting to build a
sustainable income
which in other conversations we've
already had here
like John ushai was like sustainable is
there such a thing in the greater
economy Point
um and so if that was the intent though
to not
have highs and lows you're here one day
you're gone the next we actually had
someone apply at think media that was a
full-time
YouTuber
and was gonna go full back into the
workforce totally of course respectable
but because all of his brand deals dried
up and he couldn't really rely on
AdSense so he was fully paying all of
his bills and then that all went away
and this is in the last six months wow
and so sustainable is one of those big
questions
um if you wanted to approach YouTube
with a sustainable mindset what is the
best way to earn money sustainably I
agree with your last friend though like
is there a way to make money or is it is
it you make the money where you where
you are able to find Opportunities and
then it's the way you manage it like I
could sit here and be like yeah like
because for me I make money you know
like unique way like for example like I
really primarily do brand deals I do you
know Consulting through my experiences
with the other brands I work with I kind
of upsell them on that and not everyone
can do that so I don't know I just feel
like for me it's really based on like
find like managing how cash flow
essentially right
um and to your friend that like is also
probably just honestly a byproduct of
the recession right now that I'm feeling
yep
um you know everyone's feeling like
that's okay and I think I don't think
there's a sustainable way because the
economy always goes through Epsom flows
so why do you expect as a Creator to
always maintain a similar income for me
I'm making a lot less than I did last
year like a 100 like a lot less I manage
it better because I've learned through
years but it's not easy I don't even
know a good answer that's well that's
really good the the good answer is that
there's not one way so you find out your
unique mix be smart with your money
because it might be
feasting today but it could be famine
tomorrow so if you've set something
aside and you're wise then you can write
out the ups and the downs and
and then work to your strength so you've
you have the ability to consult and do
these different things but that might
not be the model for somebody else so
really there is no one way and and AD
Revenue could is great for some channels
and they get zillions of views and it's
insane I also think there's nothing
wrong with getting a job and doing the
Creator stuff on the side too like I
mean I've never had a job job but I I
owed 100 like me and my dad joke about
this because I'm a high school dropout
and they're like Jade like you needed
like a job just to know what it's like
and like I'd be down you know I'd be
down to like know what it's like and I
don't think that's there's nothing wrong
with that sure and and there's all kinds
of hustles you could do respect the
hustle you could ubereats Uber and then
still film videos 100 you also could
then turn that into the Rideshare guy
blog and monetize you turn your hustle
uh ride share or Postmates into content
you know what's so funny so speaking on
this there's this book I'm reading
called the artist way and there's this
quote saying how do you look at every
turn around you turn as pointing me in
the right direction this year just to
like give you that think media podcast
inside tea my brand goals really got uh
postponed slash cut or whatever budget
cuts whatever most on the agency side
like my own brand deals were fine but it
allowed me to turn around and be like
wait I love making content so I don't
need to focus on like my brand work I
can focus more on my content so every
it's the way you look at it writes
perspective yeah the artist way is that
a new Rick Rubin book or is it an old
book it's an oldie okay it's oldie but a
goodie the the new Rick book do you know
who that is he's all a little viral
right now he's got the glasses oh Jolly
man with hair and beer yes yes
okay the hardest way he's like I love
him um okay as we land the plane
um
you've been known to say
creators shouldn't Niche down
um to Niche or not to Niche or to Niche
or not to Niche
I have an updated thought about this
okay let's do it okay so and so for
those who don't know I made a video like
multiple videos that went viral but like
I don't believe in a niche I think I was
going through
um a mental breakdown I was a little
unhinged I mean everyone is but I was
definitely unhinged in that moment I
felt very trapped in my own work now
here's the thing if you love what you do
and you know what you and you found
something that makes money gets views
and you like it Nisha down Nisha down
baby that's how you make that coin at
that time I wasn't there yet but I think
my updated thought is you should Nishan
if you can but if you can't Explore More
most people Niche down too quickly I
think that's a fact but I also don't my
updated thought is like I mean if you
want to get that bread you need to like
Focus so I think I think that's my
updated thought and this is something
that I'm announcing in 2023. Jade you
also speaking of some of your most
influential content you you do Trend
predictions I do it's 2023 we're going
into July
um at the time of recording so that's
for some reference what do you see
in the future and in the now I've always
said this but we're living in the world
where topical niches are already done
like if you want to search how to cook a
steak it's a video what's resurfacing
now is combination videos like think of
a smoothie right you combine cooking
with a story time that's that's the meat
you know that's that's what's doing well
you think about Alex Earl a popular tick
tock Beauty YouTuber she combines
talking about college with getting ready
and doing makeup the fusion is how you
build an audience the fusion is what
makes you unique there's already too
many videos about how to surf you know
so it's like combine something else get
at that Riz
okay so Fusion makes me think there's so
many Fusion restaurants in Las Vegas
yeah there is and that's the I mean
they're good though yeah and you're like
I wouldn't have thought of putting those
two things together but but that's a
whole experience and so Fusion is Trend
one what else
Trend two I think would be I mean it's
already a thing but like I think
podcasts is still still scratching the
surface for me it's already been done
big Deal's already been happening in the
industry but I still think more and more
creators should have podcasts because
it's really efficient way to get a lot
of content and get the Highlights turn
it into Clips
um and I think it's just a good practice
of packaging your content I think what
people are now doing a lot more is like
talking about something but how do you
make it so you like highlight the best
parts combine it into like a 30 second
60 second reel to push people into the
longer form I think that's
I mean that's really hard to do like I
struggle with that on on my podcast like
how do you find the Best Bets how do you
tell a story really quickly in the most
efficient way have you tapped into AI
yet for that yeah I think Chachi BT is
basically a better version of me for
sure right now Ivy tapped into things
like Opus clip yes which does Search
keywords and trending things and you
throw your podcast in there have you
found that to be useful yes I think a
human though knows what's funny like
I'll say like really off the cuff stuff
but in the AI won't pick it they don't
have that Riz yet I think once the AI
gets an update with that I think it's
going to be fire you know I think and
actually we have been loving Opus clip
it's definitely not perfect are you
sponsored uh we're not sponsored uh but
we're open to it presenting sponsor but
uh well we are and legit we're I mean
we're paying attention to all of them
and we're just wondering who's gonna
kind of like Edge out right I think
adobe's gonna win uh really with pulling
Clips too
feel like if it's if anyone's gonna just
copy like an existing product really
well I would make it better it's Adobe
it is that's a good point because it's
kind of an unfair advantage that they
could just go swipe it up and they are
they're bigger they have more money they
have a bigger team you know what's
interesting though is when you when it
spits out though like 10 clip the human
still has to review them and that's what
it at least has saved you time to maybe
be like oh those are cool and let me use
those and then you still edit around
them perhaps even if you did it
somewhere else yeah just by throwing
them in there keywords trending keywords
emojis or whatever else some of these
are doing so it's a crazy time we're
living in like I used to hire so many
it's kind of sad I used to hire so many
people that do things that AI does and
it's like damn like what a weird time to
be and what a scary time to be for like
a lot of people just starting too like I
mean you probably saw this industry
change so much in the past like let
alone three years you know it's like
it's weird are you saying I'm old no
Sean you're a millennial I mean you're a
older Millennial we already established
that I'm a millennial
um
I think 55 is the country I I have been
to VidCon for I think 10 years I think I
think you're old now I think I was here
I think I was here in 2023. wait as a
fan or as like a speaker 2013 2013. it's
2023 right now as a fan well so you've
been through the progression I came
um I came with Benji and I was just
super pumped to be here and I remember
Tim Ferriss was here what just chilling
and no one cared because no one here
like was like reading blogs reading four
hour work week or whatever and we were
just into session I was like is that Tim
Ferriss because he just wanted to learn
about online video and stuff damn yeah
10 years is crazy yeah I am old I I
respect and I'm a dad I got two kids you
know well I think I think the 10 years
on VidCon really speaks a lot but also
makes you so like dope like that's
awesome to say you could basically do
you not own Equity at this conference at
this point I wish you need to like you
probably built this I wonder who I think
I thought it was started by like Hank
Green right and is he he's shared it
with others and others it's owned by
Viacom now Viacom so you might need a
you might be you might be too late
yeah we have our own event it's called
growth video live it's in Las Vegas I
know and I didn't get an invite grow
with videolive.com
um is in the show notes and yeah that's
a good point and we had 17 000 speakers
last year wait 17 000 attendees right no
speakers it was I'm exaggerating but it
was It was kind of too like it was great
but it was so packed in like so many
panels and stuff because we only have
one stage we don't have 48 we don't have
three floors with 68 can I say something
right now on the podcast too let me DJ
your next uh grow a video live event
like DJ the music yeah and I can speak
too but I rather DJ
uh what like off decks yeah I'll do for
free I play violin piano like
professionally for 10 years and I now DJ
and I've been doing this for startup
events starting three days ago
sick so let me DJ okay I'll do her free
let's talk that sounds fire or you can
pay me
no let's collab like it'll be it'll be
fun we uh we need that that uh we need
the Riz yeah like if like maybe like I
can DJ like when you walk on stage
before you like an opening song like you
know something something cool like that
yeah I didn't know you did that we had a
DJ last year okay focus guy yeah it's
DJing intro music outro music anyways
okay it's called it's coming together
Saturday brainstorm about it and uh as
we land the plane I'm curious for you
what type of content has helped you
learn the most and learn the fastest if
you need a skill up as a business owner
learn new skills how do I be a CEO how
do I operate a company or how do I do
content like where have what has been
the best source of these skill sets for
you source of learning I mean is it
books is it events is it networking I'm
gonna be honest I mean this plane ride
by the way has been fantastic a little
turbulent a few times gotta tell the
captain to because he made a joke about
like we're Landing the plane okay okay
so you were so lost
that was so deep okay and I respect I'm
so grateful that you actually you were
you were trying to fly in my jet stream
I know I I love it
I had already parachuted out I mean turn
on your you didn't realize I wasn't even
in the plane anymore you literally just
left everybody's getting his baggage I
was already a baggage thing Landing the
plane it was up to you
my biggest resource for learning
honestly is unfortunately unfortunately
failing a lot you know I I read a lot of
books I mean I can name a couple like I
love subtle art I'm not giving a
it's a classic of just starting with a
mental side he just spoke he did Mark
Mason really was here by the way Manson
was just here wow Mark Mark
really he was in the first session here
today oh my gosh okay I'm a big fan but
part of being Mark Manson yeah Mark
Manson all his books are awesome okay I
also have read like you know like funnel
Secrets like all like the growth hacking
books but at the end of the day nothing
really worked until I learned from
failing you know I I mean I can name so
many failures like hiring too many
people at once I learned about how to
not make videos too long or Too Short
um and just trying a bunch of things and
I think
that is it I mean like obviously think
media duh you gotta subscribe to podcast
the newsletter to everything and my
Vlogs but other than that like I just
encourage everyone to to just be their
own little uh scientist in a lab
hypothesize good do it and then report
back Jade Dharma Longs uh really
appreciates you thanks for coming on the
podcast you mentioned they gotta
subscribe to your Vlog they don't have
to but you could
um but if like what's the stack of your
Brands and accounts worth following I
think um it's easier to follow me on
Instagram because I post pretty photos I
also I also talk in YouTube which is all
Jade Dharma wanza and if you really want
to get to know me the unhinged side my
podcast is called finessed I will say
rated R notice it's just it's just it's
just funny Jade I appreciate you really
uh grateful for the value you've added
to uh our community today and look
forward to connecting more in the future
thank you Sean I I'm again honored to be
here I thought I was too relevant but I
think I've been I've gained my trophy
back there it is